24 years ago my planet Krypton was in
serious peril
my cousin kal-el was sent to a planet
called Earth for his own safety and
protection you may know his story the
story you don't know is that I was sent
to protect him he will do extraordinary
things I love you Cara
shockwave knocked my pawn into the
Phantom Zone where time doesn't pass I
slept there for 24 years sorry I feel
like I'm not living up to my potential
sure
it's not that I don't see your frown
it's just that I don't care it much to
ask why it's there
Mayday Mayday we're going down
right in Atari you see can everyone will
know about you and you can't take that
back
I don't want to
oh my god you're hurt
welcome to the de Ville the agent
Danvers and her sister from another
plant who protect us from
extraterrestrial invasion just because
you wear that symbol on your chest
doesn't mean your head
Cara this is why you were sent here I
believe that you have to believe it too
we have eyes on the target
Supergirl we can't name her that should
she be called the super woman
earth doesn't have just one hero anymore
hey youtubers is charlie so new
Supergirl footage this is gonna be a
breakdown to that and new round of the
giveaway so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video I've also got some green
lantern news that I'll talk about after
I get done with the Supergirl stuff so
the whole point of this trailer is to
explain the age difference between Cara
and Superman and a lot of people were
wondering that because she's supposed to
be older than he is the Phantom Zone is
the way they explain that which is also
gonna be like the story device that they
use for surfacing villains on the show
or at least extraterrestrial villains I
mean I'm sure they'll be like a lot of
human villains to genre shows usually
veer into metaphors like that they say
things like people can be just as bad as
supervillains from outer space it's the
same thing with Clancy Brown on the
flash he's just as bad as any of the
rows even though technically he ends up
working with team flash whenever the
reverse flash is getting ready to suck
the earth into a giant time vortex it's
time to put differences aside in case
you haven't seen they're premiering the
show a little bit earlier than we
thought they would it's gonna be October
26 now it'll be a Monday night show
originally it wasn't gonna be till like
the beginning of November we get a nice
shot of Superman
I like the compromise that they don't
show his face but they let him be in the
pilot if you try to ask the question you
know why can't Superman be on TV like
this you're just gonna give yourself a
headache so just just forget about it
DC and Warner Brothers just want you to
think about the Henry Cavill Superman
they don't want you to have any other
broadcast related distractions
thus no face I really am excited about
all those phantoms own business we
haven't spent a lot of time there in the
TV universe yet and now that the flash
has figured out special effects on a TV
budget I think there are a lot of places
they could go with this there's some
unique challenges they're doing a
Kryptonian show in that the villains
have to be just as strong as the
superhero and when you're not
indestructible it's really hard to find
a convincing villain and a lot of people
are always wondering why Barry derps a
lot on the flash like what you know why
he doesn't have all those powers like
right away why can't phase immediately
it takes him a while to figure it out
that's kind of gonna be the same thing
with Kara zor-el Kara Danvers will be
her human name but like she explains in
the trailer her mission is to protect
her cousin kal-el but obviously she gets
there
he's already been around for about 25
years so he doesn't need her help
that's what fee though you know what the
hell do I do with my life storyline like
oh [ __ ] does this planet need me what am
I supposed to do here
what am I supposed to do with my life
the only issue I take with that is the
idea of superheroes waking up and not
wanting their superpowers that's not and
that's not the case here the flash did a
really good job of addressing that so
I'm hoping Supergirl kind of follows up
on that theme one of the really fun
things about Kryptonians especially a
Supergirl in the comics is that she
doesn't pull punches like Superman does
this version of the character is much
more nascent like the one in the trailer
that we see she's not super angry yet
which is really what it takes for
Superman and any other Kryptonians to go
crazy on people the brief tease of the
action sequences really don't do it
justice they smash the [ __ ] out of some
sets I go so far as to say is that was
one of the hardest things for them to
figure out like how does she fight
because it's not gonna be Krav Maga like
Oliver it's not gonna be like down and
dirty and it's not gonna be like Barry
where he just super speeds around people
Superman by contrast is one of those
characters that doesn't really need to
be a good fighter because he is a god so
a lot of the fun of his fights are the
unexpected ways in which he uses his
powers the hand clap is one of my
favorite it's a lot like the flash
finger snap or the reverse-flash finger
snap I should say they didn't do that on
the flash season one so maybe they'll
bring it out in season two so I think
we'll start to see her get way more
creative with their powers towards the
end of the season this is a good
question which new power do you want
carrots to get by the end of the season
that we haven't seen on TV or in the
movies yet a lot of my hope for this
show is that they'll do something really
interesting with the Phantom Zone which
is just like a lego place we haven't
spent a whole lot of time within the TV
and movie universes there aren't a lot
of preconceived notions about that other
than the fact that they used to banish
criminals there anyway it's gonna be a
lot of fun I'm really looking forward to
the series generally like when series
first started out I have pretty low
expectations usually season 2 season 3
is when stuff gets crazy so you just
have to be patient Gotham was not so hot
when it first started out but season 2
is actually looking pretty badass I'll
be doing some Gotham videos too pretty
soon but on to Green Lantern's stuff
Tyrese is teasing that he might be part
of Green Lanterns if that really is the
direction they're going with the
franchise I'd be totally open to that
John Stuart great character obviously
they always want to go with Hal Jordan
first because he's the Green Lantern
that everybody knows and it's all about
familiarity when you're trying to launch
a movie but this is potentially so far
off in the future that it doesn't really
matter that much
most the focus is gonna be on Batman V
Superman or appropriately at Comic Con
but do not be surprised as they drop
stuff about the other movies like
Aquaman Green Lantern's the flash team
up movie the most interesting thing
about the flash movie is that it's being
written by Lord and Miller think the
guys that did the lego movie basically
lego movie and 21 Jump Street by the
time we get to that though I mean Greg
us and will have been the flash for
almost like five years so he will for
all intents and purposes be the Barry
Allen that we're familiar with and don't
forget to the Warner Brothers TV panel
is also gonna drop a bunch of legends of
tomorrow stuff so I'll probably be doing
a new legends of tomorrow video soon so
a bunch of stuff happening this weekend
I'll try get that Supergirl review up as
fast as possible hopefully by a Saturday
at least I have a spider-man villain
video and I'll be doing some Arkham
Knight gameplay on my game channel links
for all that important stuff down in the
description below but while you wait for
everything to post you can click here to
learn all about the flash season 2 and
arrow season 4 premieres and you can
click here for my Game of Thrones Q&A
that I just posted last night thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight